this one's from Bradford I think access
is the key to releasing yourself from
overconsumption
I'd love to hear how to determine what
you need to own versus what you have
access to and then he makes a very good
point here underwear falls into the
ownership camp I assume thank God Ron
are you wearing the other word a day was
it me I'm not wearing any underwear
well yeah I think so what Bradford is
saying here is yeah it's a good question
I think access is the key to releasing
yourself from overconsumption yeah but
but also maybe but also when I think
about this like I don't think there's a
such thing as too much access but I
think there is a thing as taking
advantage of too much access yeah you
can you can skew the complete other way
so the same way you get your worth from
you know if you're getting your entire
worth self-worth from the things that
you own you're buying these things for
your own ego what we talked about
earlier you could do that you could go
the same thing on the access route yeah
you know you could you know rent all the
cool stuff and you know do do all that
just to feed the same emotion yeah and
so it's not I don't think access is
inherently good and ownership is
inherently bad but I think it's all
about setting yourself up to be able to
live the life that you want to live well
yeah I mean he you know he said he wants
you know you'd like to hear us to talk
about what you need to own versus what
you need to have access to and that's
gonna be different for every single
person yeah everyone's got different
preferences everyone has different needs
me and Mariah we don't have any kids so
we don't need any kids stuff but you
guys you guys need kids stuff yeah
there's like this toy warehouse down on
Miracle Mile and like mostly inspired by
Derek Siver's a conversation I have with
him especially we did this we filmed it
too I will eventually do something with
the footage we had this backstage
conversation with him now backstage was
a weird conference room we were at a
horse track it was the strangest thing
ever but we had this conversation with
him about like owning toys and and the
thing he talked about on stage is like
well you can't be minimalist with kids
or whatever and I think Ryan pushed back
a little bit and said well you know you
if you bought ten boxes of toys for your
kids
he's not gonna be any happier within
with that one box it and so there was an
appropriate mat amount but I realized
that when the babysitter would come over
Chrissy and and babysit Ella she's like
where's her toys and I'm like they're
right there both of them you know like
not not not literally but like I
realized like oh yeah I should probably
get more toys for Ella and not like
force this lifestyle on to her now I did
this video with Ella recently during the
living room conversations we were like
putting together this toy set it was
like Legos don't forget what it was
called but she wouldn't we were building
this hospital so she could inject things
into these little mannequins or whatever
I don't know whatever he said though and
and what I realized like by going and
buying that stuff is like what is the
appropriate amount because the the study
I saw is the average child owns nearly
300 toys but plays with only 12 daily
yeah and that goes back to the this
whole thing of are we just buying a
bunch of sort of distractions and
pacifiers or are these things that the
kids will really get a lot of value from
and if they stop getting value from it
the thing that we do with Ella is we
just have her donate it and she realizes
why they donate it because some other
kid will be able to play with it yeah
yeah I think when it comes to the
ownership versus access for me like
having having rules like for the things
that I own meaning like the ninety nine
year old that Josh and I have basically
you know anything that I haven't used in
the last 90 days and if I really think
about it not gonna use in the next 90
days I probably would get rid of it
there are a few things like seasonal
items like a winter jacket or snowboard
course don't like it's gonna be adjust
for one rather than a just in case yeah
but I think like that's the quite that
see that people need to do if they want
to really be clear on okay what do I
need to have access to and what do I
need to own what rules do you have for
yourself is it ninety ninety maybe for
someone else it's six months six months
or maybe it's a year it doesn't matter
what the number is to help us determine
what we need to own versus what we have
to have access to I think yes we need to
look at our preferences look at our
situation but also just create
some boundaries for ourselves to kind of
keep us from from over yes
over-consuming I think Brad's got a
really good point
the oh shoot I lost it a lot had another
thought but then I lost it
no I I mean just kind of going off of
what Brad was talking about here yes you
don't have to you don't have to have
access to underwear you should own
underwear and I hope I hope what I hope
is that technology can help us because
if you think about you know 10 years ago
if you needed a car to get to work even
occasionally there was no Zipcar there
was no get around there's no Oberer
there was no lift Ryan took an uber here
today because accidents yeah there you
go
taxes were taxis not even impossible to
call where you lived and so you might
actually have needed to own a car and
now it could be totally feasible
a decade later to not own a car right
and what I'm hoping we see is that you
know a huge wave of you know basically
technology platforms that allow us to
own you know that sphere that circle
basically grows where now it's sort of
you can get access to cars really easily
but then what if there's that next wave
out of things you could get access to
and the next wave out after that because
it's all about how easy you can get
access to it if you have to drive two
hours to go rent a stroller for the nine
months you have a kid you're not gonna
do that you're gonna just buy a stroller
and Amazon it but if you get that to
deliver to your house and rent it for
nine months you might be way more likely
to do that yeah and so I think about the
very first time we went out on on tour
basically this guy was using Omni before
Omni existed we were in Albuquerque
remember in the guy came out to us
afterward and said hey I need a chainsaw
and they like once or twice a year and
so I will go to my storage locker and
get it and then when I I'll use it and
then I'll put it back on on the storage
locker when I'm done and that storage
locker is called Craigslist and so he's
like I'll buy it for 25 bucks or 30
bucks or a hundred bucks and I'll sell
it back for roughly the same price as
soon as I'm done and I'm like man one
day there's going to be an uber for
chainsaws and and here it is and now
there is one
you